[Music]
hello everybody the rush to escape the
taliban continues this morning in
afghanistan there are still huge crowds
of people outside kabul airport as
people try to get a flight out of the
country nato confirmed today that 12
people have died either by stampede or
gunshot
the latest raf flight carrying both
british and afghan citizens arrived back
in the uk in the early hours of this
morning let's speak to our middle east
correspondent ali bunkel who's standing
by for us this morning so the airlift
continues ali but one wonders for how
much longer
yeah that is the great worry that the
taliban uh now control the city of kabul
and to that effect they control the
roads in and out of the airport and it
might be that
at any point they decide they want their
international airport back and they want
to take control of that uh crossing in
and out of of the country now we know
that there is dialogue going on between
the british and the americans and the
taliban both and you know the defense
secretary who you're about to speak to
uh told you this last time he
interviewed you he was using qatar as a
as an interlocutor uh to talk to the
taliban but actually we know that the
british forces on the ground are now
stationed um literally some meters away
so by the side of barbed wire from the
taliban and so there is an element of
communication going on uh
pretty much face to face which i mean
it's just extraordinary when you
consider that they've spent 20 years
as enemies uh they are now managing to
uh create some sort of communication in
order to process anyone wanting to leave
the country but it is messy it is
incredibly chaotic and it is deeply sad
now that we're gonna show you some
pictures that i should warn you are very
distressing
but they do
highlight
just in them
the most bluntest of ways how desperate
people are to get themselves and their
family members out of the country and
this is one of the fences on the
outskirts
of kabul international airport and you
see people passing their children
over the fence to
british and american soldiers
they are that desperate to get out of
afghanistan that they are willing
to give up their children so that they
can go
to safety that they can go to a better
life a life uh that is not living under
the taliban and i think if you want any
kind of illustration
as to how desperate these people are it
cannot uh become starker
than that and on the other side of the
fence let's not forget that you have
in many cases very young
men and women british soldiers men and
women who are having to
not just witness these scenes
but in so many cases every single day
make decisions
over who is allowed to board a flight
and who is sent back into kabul and
whatever fate awaits them and that is an
extremely
uh
difficult
and upsetting task for the british armed
forces to be making
but they are doing so and they are
processing as many as they can
to get onto flights
but
they will not be able to
take everybody out of the country who
wants to
some people don't have a legitimate
reason uh to do so but you can just see
here just how many thousands i want to
get on one of those flights they don't
care where they go they don't care
whether they go to america or the uk or
elsewhere in europe or elsewhere in the
world they just want to leave kabul
okay for now um alastair thanks um have
a listen to what the secretary of state
for defense has to say ben wallace is
joining us
again now hello to you mr wallace uh
thank you as usual for joining us on the
program we do appreciate it we
understand how many challenges you're
facing at the moment uh let's start with
your understanding of the latest
situation uh on the ground um the
taliban do seem to be uh tightening
their grip women
eyewitnesses are telling us that women
are throwing their babies over razor
wire to british soldiers what's your
understanding
so
first of all um the taliban are letting
through our people
uh to the processing center so there is
uh i read some earlier reports today
that
in the media that that wasn't that
wasn't the case it is the case that the
plus side is
the taliban the the work that's been
done on the ground they have allowed our
people through
uh and uh that is uh obviously good news
for both our afghan uh friends but also
for any
entitled personnel british passport
holders etcetera
the the challenge is obviously they're
letting everyone through and that's why
you're seeing these crowd issues at the
different gates around the airport at 6
00 this morning i spoke to our commander
on the ground there
it is very very difficult for those
soldiers as you've seen in your own
footage dealing with some desperate
desperate people
many of whom are just wanting to leave
the country
and you see obviously that our soldiers
are having to deal with crowd control
which is a different type of threat than
a
an enemy threat or a security threat so
we're finding our way through that we're
getting through it um we reinforced
yesterday with another company of
soldiers flown in
to make sure that the public order was
held
at bay uh we are
in a process that is more mature than uh
some of the other countries so we are
bringing people forward calling them
forward uh the arab scheme that's the
scheme that we started back in april
that's a much more mature scheme people
are getting through and they're getting
on the planes
and we will fly them out
and
the other thing is we are not sending
out any empty planes um we haven't sent
out a single empty plane so far
if we have any spare capacity at any
stage we make sure we share it with
other nations to fly out their key
personnel such as we flew out some nato
personnel and some of the nato
interpreter afghans for them to make
sure that not a single seat is wasted
and we're coordinating with the other
countries okay let's let's play through
some of my other questions if i may
first of all very quickly um what's
happening to the babies that are being
taken by the squaddies
i don't know i mean in the footage i've
seen them uh if they are families that
are coming through as a whole they will
come through uh right now as we're
speaking i think we're loading up 120
families onto a plane
to depart another 138 uh only a few uh
hours later uh we'll be rolling through
that process we we have uh it's a
24-hour airport now for military planes
and they're getting through uh obviously
we can't just take a minor on their own
and
you know it is it is difficult but
you'll find as you see in the footage i
think you're showing now the child has
taken that will be because the family
will be taken as well it'll be their
challenge trying to make it through that
crowd we are finding other ways of
dealing with that but that is what's
happening
let's play on if i may please mr wallace
um we can also see that these lots of
these squadies are you know little more
than children themselves um the
diplomats shipped out you are sending
youngsters in to try to deal with life
and death decisions is that fair
well
two things the the everyone in that
chain is having a very stressful time
because whether you're the person who
has to front up to an afghan family and
say you're not eligible uh or you know
you you you you weren't part of the
british scheme that's going to be tough
and then obviously the soldiers doing
public duty you have to absolutely uh
deal with the people that approach them
and that is also tough you know i don't
think there isn't an alternative where i
can keep soldiers away from the public
that is that is the mission they're on
uh but uh what we're trying to do is
make sure that we disappoint as few
people as possible and through the night
uh last night my minister and the junior
ministers in in the other departments
have been working to try and speed up
what we call the back office process
that's the you know receiving the the
names from the crisis hub making sure
they're processed and screened as
quickly as possible so that there's
almost no delay when they turn up at the
airport that that is the key there are
things to
to to rule out we're going to do that
and i change it every hour if we have to
change something we'll change it okay mr
wallace i'm sorry i have to interrupt
but there's a lot to get through do you
agree with your chief of the defence
staff um yesterday who told me on this
program that the taliban i quote him are
a group of country boys who live by a
code of honour
well the taliban are clearly a military
force
uh they have their own disciplined sets
uh i'm not saying that in a way that uh
nor was the chief's fed staff there was
any admiration for those people uh in
that sense but we're also trying to deal
with the facts on the ground you know my
local commanders on the ground have
engaged with the locals i'm sorry mr
wallace my question specifically is
about what the chief of the defense
staff not on the ground here he says
they are a group of country boys who
live by a code of honor and that they
have changed doesn't look like that from
eyewitness reports that we're reading in
the newspapers this morning
i think he also said that he will see if
they change you know look
we are where we are the taliban are
running the country sending him mr
wallace
of course i'm defending him look nick
carter knows more than i'll ever know
about afghanistan the taliban and more
than most people uh uh he is a deeply
experienced general both both as a
general before he was a general serving
in afghanistan and you know when he says
things we should listen and we should
value it he is my advisor the prime
minister's advisor and he is absolutely
right in some of his observations about
where we were going and he is right that
a lot of the taliban don't come from the
sophisticated parts of the afghanistan
they may come from country the
countryside and not be as sophisticated
as some of the previous political class
but but that doesn't mean to say that
the taliban are not running the country
they're running the country we have to
deal with that as we may we're obviously
not recognizing them as a government at
the moment but we have to locally engage
them
okay let's talk about your foreign
secretary instead then should we um if
he had made a call from his crete stone
launcher last friday to his afghan
counterpart which the u.s
opposite number did then more
interpreters would have been out of that
country
by now wouldn't they
uh okay i like you i've read the front
of the newspaper today i have absolutely
no idea about what my foreign secretary
or anyone else actually call sheet is
like
what i do know
is that at no stage in the last few
weeks i had a problem with the foreign
secretary or anyone else in that
department in making sure we can process
get people through
you know the facts are changing rapidly
on the ground
and uh you know as as he said yesterday
in parliament he's managed to do all his
calls when he needed to his cobra calls
et cetera
he didn't mr wallace he didn't he didn't
call
he didn't call it and he's admitted the
foreign office has admitted this on the
front page of the paper today he had
they admitted that he didn't make the
call to his afghan counterpart you know
the diplomacy in that part of the world
it has to be on a similar level of
diplomat or of politician in order to
make things happen he said he was too
busy the americans weren't too busy and
a lot of their interpreters they've
managed to get to the airport in good
time ours are now sheltering in place
and can't get there
look okay
one phone call is not the reason we are
where we are at the moment and i don't
even know if that phone call deal didn't
happen because all we have is a media
speculative front page about it what i
will say very clearly it's very
dismissive of you mr wallace i'm i'm not
being dismissive okay what i'm saying is
you know the idea i am focused on one
front page of a newspaper at 6 30 in the
morning uh when my constituents and you
as a taxpayer expect me to be dealing
with the problem on the ground
you must have been in uh
with the foreign secretary yes i have
i've been he's he's taken my calls i've
been next door but one two yesterday
yeah i i've had
as i said earlier i've had no problem
today in dealing with the foreign
secretary or the foreign office
throughout this process that we have we
have lent in and we have dealt with the
issues of the as they were as they were
presented and i think the other thing
that we should point out as we know is
that you know that afghan government the
one that melted away pretty quickly i'm
not sure how much leverage they had on
the ground anyhow at that particular
moment in time because that was not the
challenges i was facing at that time
last friday those were not the problems
the barriers for us getting people out
the problems if you remember and you
reported on it was about whether we
could get the airport open and whether
people could be using the airport as the
taliban advanced that was the best
soldiers are doing their level best and
there is no criticism for their work
let me ask you about the criticism for
your prime minister though you were in
the house of commons as i said yesterday
your former brothers in arms absolutely
savaged him how difficult was it for you
sitting there listening to all of that
it wasn't difficult for any of us
listening to what is quite rightly a
real outpouring of anger uh frustration
and sadness about what we are seeing on
the ground in afghanistan and you know
some of that anger is vented towards all
of us you know i get pretty unpleasant
emails from lots of people every day
about these sort of things i understand
why
i understand
you know the deep disappointment
of what happened over the last two years
in the doha agreement
and you know people wanted to say if you
listen if you go over the debate today
again if you have the time to listen to
it again you'll realize that a lot of
that debate was people expressing their
deep frustration and fear that we have a
different world than we did that we all
took for granted and you know i didn't
hear alternative solutions from anybody
including my colleagues who were
criticizing us except one some of our
colleagues suggested that the british go
back in again as an army i don't think
anyone feels sending unilaterally a
single force in of tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of troops
would be the right solution now
but but apart from that there was long
on criticism and very short on solutions
let me ask you one final question before
i let you go i'm sorry to to rush you
you say that we didn't know what was
going to happen last week uh on last
sunday in afghanistan uh in kabul in
particular the u.s
just need to ask you this final question
before i let you go the us president um
has been subject to quite a lot of
criticism as well he said that he
expected the chaos that we're seeing at
the airport as a result of the cowboy of
the taliban moving in so quickly and he
factored that into his decision making
did we
do we yes we always knew so what you'll
see now op fitting operation
wasn't made up last week okay it was
made up we worked it out planned it at
last april this april which so you know
you don't we didn't just send our troops
in sort of on a random plan it was a
plan we made the plan the only question
was always the interpreters to the
airport earlier why didn't we get them
there earlier why didn't we say to
people who needed to come to the uk come
because we know there's going to be
chaos
okay before the chaos that we saw at the
airport we've taken out nearly 2 000. so
we have been doing that
there's been a long steady stream of
families and afghan interpreters coming
to this country we're now over 3 000
with people with their families but
since april to literally last weekend we
were taking a steady stream we were
changing the rules uh you know we were
we were waiving requirements uh so we'd
taken i think it was 1800 1900 out alone
by the time we got to last friday
many many thousands still left behind
yep but we are processing us through
we'll we'll call forward nearly 2 000
over the next few days
okay good to talk to you i'll have to
let you go thank you very much indeed
again thank you bye-bye what is life
like uh under the taliban at hapa7 we'll
speak to pashtani durrani in afghanistan
whose charity tries to get girls into
education what's happening
740 dr scholler and scotty nell hughes
will both be with us they'll be talking
to us about joe biden's speech and who
he's blaming who he isn't
and a month since freedom day is the
wedding industry starting to recover
[Music]
the latest raf flight carrying british
and afghan nationals arrived at rf
bryson norton overnight at charlotte
lomas has the latest from there now
hello to charlotte we're just hearing
there from the defense secretary um
almost another 300 people heading your
way
exactly kay good morning to you more
flights arriving here at raf bryce
norton every day we understand from the
prime minister that they are aiming to
evacuate 1 000 british nationals and
afghans here um every day we haven't got
the precise numbers from the ministry of
defence but you heard ben wallace the
defence secretary just then just saying
that 120 families are on a plane heading
to the uk and 2 000 more over the next
couple of days
there is another question mark though
that's to how long um the british troops
have to evacuate everyone so far there
has been any hasn't been any resistance
from the taliban to the allied
withdrawal but the worry is or the
question is how long will that continue
so there is pressure to make this
evacuation
obviously as quick as possible and for
those afghan nationals who do arrive
back in here they do manage to escape
the taliban what then the question is
what will happen to them when they come
back to the uk where will they go
they do face an uncertain future as they
try to integrate into new homes and new
communities okay charlotte thank you
a man believed to be the last surviving
khmer rouge leader is due in court this
morning
ninety-year-old kiyou samfan is
appealing against his conviction for
genocide our southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins joining us
now from bangkok um hello to you siobhan
uh tell us more about what's gonna
happen today
yes so the court is already underway
kusupon is in court and he is the last
living leader of the kaimou rouge he was
in pol pot's inner circle and you'll
remember that the kaimuri ruled cambodia
with an iron fist between 1975 and 1979
they're accused of crimes including
genocide torture rape
in slavery murder crimes against
humanity and kusapan is in court because
he's been appealing a conviction from
2018 where he was uh convicted of
genocide against vietnamese he's been
appealing that all week he's been
sitting in court the 90-year-old and
later today he's expected to actually
address the court as this appeal hearing
draws to a close now we're not expecting
a judgment today what we are expecting
is um final
wrapping up of this very long running
procedure and this tribunal has actually
been running for 15 years he's just a
part of it even if the conviction is
overturned and we don't expect an
announcement on that until 2022 it's
worth noting that he was already
convicted and serving life in prison for
other crimes against humanity but this
is a very important moment for many
cambodians 1.7 million cambodians died
during that rule of the khmer rouge and
this is a moment for them to watch some
sort of justice being brought against
the former leaders
okay for now thank you
hospitals in haiti say they are running
short of food and medical supplies in
the wake of saturday's earthquake more
than
2 000 people are now known to have died
in the disaster
two vaccine doses is still the most
effective way to ensure protection
against the delta variant of coronavirus
researchers from oxford university
concluded both the pfizer and
astrazeneca jabs offer a similar level
of protection after four to five months
a u.s prosecutor has told a jury that r
b singer r kelly is a predator whose
fame brought him access to girls boys
and young men the three-time grammy
winner has pleaded not guilty to charges
of racketeering sexual abuse and bribery
officials in california say another
major wildfire has broken eight a broken
out 80 miles from san francisco
firefighters say forests planted to help
combat climate change are likely to be
destroyed
and you can keep up with all the stories
affected by the global climate on the
daily climate show right here on sky
news every weekday 6 30 and 9 30.
for the thousands of afghans living in
britain the seizure of power by the
taliban is deeply troubling most still
have family living in afghanistan and
are struggling to stay in touch with
them our scotland correspondent james
matthews visited a british afghan
community in
glasgow a corner of glasgow that is
forever afghanistan when united take the
field
glasgow afghan united are a team created
by refugees
today with one eye on the action in the
place and on the close relatives they
left behind
my grandfather and my grandmother are in
the middle of war and they're scared
with the rest of their family my uncles
and my aunties one of my
main worries is about the women rights
and the fear of the people who do not
have any power or any
self-confidence of going outside and
doing their normal day-to-day jobs
the team is run by abdul bostani who
fled afghanistan 20 years ago
he doesn't worry for his young family
here but for the relatives hunkered down
in kabul
everything is wrong
on the phone from the afghan capital his
younger brother told of people being
taken away from their homes in the night
the door was not and
some people had came
from taliban they asked
these people and took them away they're
taking people's car they are taking
people's empty houses
lots of people have fled left the
country so the houses have been taken by
the taliban and it is so difficult and
terrifying to see what is happening
britain and america decided to go to
afghanistan in glasgow this was a
gathering organized in solidarity with
the people of afghanistan
it should be said that views do vary
here on events
wahid totokil is the chairman of the
scottish afghan society a registered
charity he's also a supporter of the
taliban takeover
afghanistan safe than europe
now
why are people hanging onto airplanes to
try to escape
this not afghan people not all
afghanistan people to behind of the
airplane there's under its
or 200 or 500 people they listened to
the
america and canada news they said we'd
take
3 30 000 i've gone to canada and they
said oh they take and they went to the
airport
it's clear the uncertainty of the
situation in afghanistan has some way to
play out
as it does it resonates far from there
here too they fear the end game
james matthews sky news glasgow
[Music]
doing the best they can to relax while
they wait to hear word of their
relatives still stock in kabul and
greater afghanistan what's happening
here as far as the weather is concerned
kirsty is standing by for us this
morning good morning kirsty tell me more
good morning kate well for many of us
it's another case of more cloudy skies
fairly damp conditions as well this
morning a few spits and spots of rain
and drizzle there are signs things will
warm up this weekend but unfortunately
we've got a weather front moving in as
well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's a gray and damp start
for many with spits and spots of light
rain and drizzle it will be a very
different feeling day for parts of
central eastern scotland and northeast
england after yesterday's warm sunshine
it's cloudy skies and spots of rain and
noticeably cooler as well we've got some
showery rain pushing its way from
eastern ireland into wales later on into
central parts of england and some of
these showers that develop this
afternoon could be on the heavy side for
most though we're just slowly watching
the cloud and hoping it might break up a
little bit so perhaps a few glimmers of
afternoon sunshine but just bear in mind
there could be a few heavy showers
around those will fade tonight much of
it and largely dry if cloudy with some
hill fog rainbow pushing in across
ireland and this rain will push its way
north eastwards on friday
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
we all need a bit of levity don't we
let's check up on wally should we he
said little monkey he's been spotted
again this time using a speedboat
as his own personal sofa off the coast
of west cork in ireland it's the latest
sighting it continues what's turning
into a two and a half thousand mile trip
around europe there he is 800 kilos of
him he's using boats to take naps which
can last
several days so he's just relaxing in
his own personal speedboat
good on him
um coming up in just a few moments time
we'll return to the situation on the
ground in afghanistan president biden
facing criticism on all sides over his
decision to withdraw u.s troops we'll
discuss that with dr schola and also
scotty nell hughes is with us do stay
tuned
[Music]
[Applause]
morning again everybody the defence
secretary says conditions in kabul for
british soldiers aren't very difficult
the rush to escape the afghan capital
continues this morning nato says 12
people have died either by stampede or
gunshots around the airport ben wallace
told me that for the time being the
taliban are allowing people to go to the
airport
the taliban are letting through our
people
to the processing center so there is
i read some early reports today that
in the media that that wasn't that
wasn't the case it is the case that the
plus side is
the taliban the the work that's been
done on the ground they have allowed our
people through
uh and uh that is uh obviously good news
for both our afghan
friends but also for any
entitled personnel british passport
holders etc
the the challenge is obviously they're
letting everyone through and that's why
you're seeing these crowd issues at the
different gates around the airport at 6
30 this morning i spoke to our commander
on the ground there
it is very very difficult for those
soldiers as you've seen in your own
footage dealing with some desperate
desperate people
tomorrow's with us this morning hello to
tomorrow he did say about another 300
people or there abouts are about to take
off to come to a new life in the uk but
so many more not that's right and ben
wallace said that in in response to
reports that some of these planes are
leaving half full he said that was not
the case that the taliban are if
anything allowing too many people
through so you have these distressing
scenes at the airport where people who
don't have the right paperwork are being
turned away and he says where there is
spare capacity on planes they've given
it to other countries or to nato
personnel who we've brought back so he
says it is all proceeding smoothly but
of course up against the clock with the
ambassador saying we've got days and not
weeks and he backed his man didn't he um
nick carter when we were talking about
he says that they're a group of country
boys and they're to be trusted yes and a
lot of coverage in the papers today of
that interview with nick carter who is
regarded as an expert in the region he's
been brokering peace talks between
afghan leaders over the past year saying
perhaps the taliban have changed perhaps
they're not
engaging in medieval behavior anymore
that would be horrifying to many
particularly women who were stuck in
afghanistan in fear but ben wallace said
when he speaks we should listen and he
is someone who understands the situation
on the ground just a quick thought we're
about to do an interview in the united
states uh biden has been heavily
criticized for saying we knew this was
going to happen what's the problem and
ben wallace saying yeah we knew too
yes it seems that leaders are trying to
have it both ways boris johnson
yesterday saying we didn't foresee this
but then we did foresee it as well so i
think that is the subject of a lot of
criticism of course how did the
intelligence get it so wrong or why did
political leaders ignore that
intelligence and in the debate yesterday
i think probably joe biden took more
criticism than the prime minister for
failing to act with other nato allies to
make sure that this chaos could to some
extent be averted but the message from
ben wallace was very much that mps were
long on criticism and short on solutions
none of them want to send troops back
there and therefore there was very
little he says that they offered in
terms of alternatives okay tomorrow's
take at nine o'clock lee then forward to
it thanks so much indeed meantime let's
talk about president bison biden uh that
speech he made earlier on in the week
and the criticism that he received as a
result um dr schola and scotty will be
with us in just a second but first this
i don't think it could have been handled
in a way that
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
i don't know how that happened so for
you that was always priced into the
decision yes
was it though well
buckle up dr scholler and scotty are
here um scott is shaking ahead morning
you start then scotty
well that's the thing it's such a shame
to hear the president of the united
states absolutely say that he priced in
the chaos while he's on vacation and he
comes and he speaks and he addresses not
only the united states but the world as
people are dying while he's left more
than 10 000 americans in afghanistan
right now unable to get home unable to
get to safety and he says he priced that
in i think this has been an absolute
failure and i think right now there's
never been more damage done to the
united states and our reputation on the
global scale to protect to protect our
allies and to help than what has been
done in the last two weeks and it's not
whether it's a failure of our
intelligence our intelligence told the
president and this administration they
just failed to listen and i think there
should be some strict
some quick investigations into how the
america got it so wrong in their
withdrawal process we don't we all agree
that the united states needed to get out
of the area i think all of us did 20
years is way too long but how this has
been handled has been so of such poor
judgment i don't even think people in
joe biden's own party can defend it okay
dr shola how difficult is it to defend
the uh democrat president
there is no defending the indefensible
as far as i'm concerned and i say this
is one who supports joe biden's
presidency as far as i'm concerned the
execution of the afghanistan withdrawal
is totally unju abiding don't get me
wrong i totally get that joe biden has
been boxed in by trump's own policy um
the fact that in this past few years the
taliban were empowered
by the weakness of america on the ground
trump pulled out thousands of troops
trump was the one that um that demanded
that 5 000 taliban prisoners be released
all of these decisions that we made all
aided what we find today but there is no
denying that the withdrawal was on and
is on joe biden's watch so the utter
chaos we are seeing is on this watch as
far as i'm concerned it was preventable
it was avoidable and when you know when
study talks about
oh this just shows a great weakness no i
don't doubt that better judgment should
have been applied but please this thing
happened overnight this is taking four
years to get here so whatever we are
seeing today as far as i'm concerned
afghans who have supported and helped
americans on the ground they must not be
left behind this must not be a case of
america using and dumping people once
again americans who are still in
afghanistan should be pulled out safely
what we must see right here with the uk
with the u.s and its allies is that they
must pay the price for going into
afghanistan for turning the country into
what it is to do because they all
contributed to it and we must understand
that this is important we cannot leave
allies behind and all those afghans
journalists activists women young girls
so many of them risk their lives okay to
help americans help british people on
the ground okay let's bring in scotty
scottie to what extent does uh president
trump have to accept some responsibility
he held up a big sign saying dear
taliban we're coming out before the 11th
of september
absolutely he actually posted that he
wanted to make sure that the american
soldiers were pulled out but there's a
complete difference to how trump would
handle it but i'm actually going to back
it up past trump i'm going to actually
put this in the fact of president obama
in the eight years that he was in office
in the chaos let's remember president
obama pulled troops out he released he
released prisoners he sent troops back
in this is not just for one president
republican or democrat this all the way
goes back to the very beginning and the
reason why we said that we were going
into afghanistan in the first place this
has been used as a major money maker for
the contractors the industrial military
complex that totally reeks and has such
a fierce hold in washington dc they have
just thrown money and thrown weapons at
it and unfortunately what we're seeing
is going to be all of that money on
weaponry and machinery and all of the
things that cause mass destruction we
literally just left it for the
terrorists for our enemies who we've
been fighting which is not only
insulting to those families and those
soldiers who lost loved ones over there
in the last 20 years but it's very scary
to know what's going to happen in the
future how emboldened they are
especially when you have countries like
china that are already saying we are
going to recognize the taliban as equal
and other countries and say you know
what we'll actually do trade with them
this is not the type of government that
is going to be just trade folk it's
going to try to build itself
economically we're already seeing the
horror and the street but is how the
world is going to deal with it i know
one thing they're going to do they're
not going to rely on the united states
next time to try to handle the peace in
that situat in that in that region
well let me just add this i think it's
all well and good if we want to go all
the way back but if you're going to go
all the way back you should go all the
way to the beginning from bush and blair
up till today i think that the point
here is that we find that with western
allies the moment they lose strategic
interest in a country they dump that
country faster than you can say the the
country's name and that's what's
happened with afghanistan they have the
heartbreaking scenes we see in the
airport is because as far as i'm
concerned there was no clear thought out
and plan to be able to withdraw people
and i would like to say this look as far
as i'm concerned joe biden
may not have been able to deal with a
lot of the things that trump had already
put in place and remember trump has only
just said recently that he set joe biden
up but i cannot i cannot for the life of
me understand why
i cannot for the life of me understand
why if america can send 6 000 troops in
now why those thousands of troops could
not have been sent in before may 1st to
ensure you know to ensure that this
chaos doesn't happen to each other the
taliban does not just swoop in i do
think that your body made a compelling
case as to why america could not remain
but he did not answer the question this
was no longer about why america should
stay or leave this was about well if
you're going to go you can't just leave
your allies hanging you can't just leave
women young girls um journalists
activists those who raised their lives
just hanging and that is what is totally
out of place here and there was no
meaningful commitment drawn from the
taliban before america left so and this
is not just um the u.s it's also the uk
it's also the uk so much more needs to
be done and let me just say this
let's say people that are pointing hands
at joe biden the republicans all of them
even in this country that say oh no look
at what is happening in afghanistan the
same people who are going to demonize
fleeing afghan refugees because they
don't want african refugees in the uk or
in the us is that right scotty i do want
to add one
i do want to add one thing on to what
she said it's it's not just about joe
biden what he's doing in this bag i
think like i said we can all agree that
soldiers needed to go the bigger issue
on this is why why did he not listen to
his intelligence how could you be so
blindsided supposedly when anybody from
the outside looking in and i don't think
america just dumped afghanistan i think
that's exactly opposite considering the
billions of dollars that we've spent the
2 300 lives of servicemen and women that
we've lost we're not just dumping
afghanistan we should have left a long
time ago the question is why are we
doing it so irresponsibly and you're
right it what it is speak volume from
the fact that our pentagon our state
department stood up today and said that
they could not go in and rescue these
americans and rescue those that have
helped us for those nationals that have
helped us for the last 20 years i don't
believe that to be true not with
everything that america has been able to
accomplish i guarantee if they wanted to
go in there and get those people out of
there they should be able to and i know
they can't the problem is just so
disorganized between the state
department the white house as well as
the pentagon for so can we get them all
in the room maybe they get off vacation
and actually pay attention to the world
and the chaos that they've created by
their laughter
to be fed your body and did get off his
vacation go to the white house
he didn't i don't
think an intelligence breakdown because
from what we know of joe biden aside
from the fact that he's an empathetic
leader we know for a fact that he does
listen to intelligence i think that this
he was either grossly misinformed i
think he should have known better
because even the layman on the street
knew that the taliban
would swoop in the moment the west you
know leaves their borders so i don't buy
the whole the whole um narrative around
well you know what there will never be a
situation where there'll be a helicopter
you know taking fleeing americans off
the roof i never bought into that
because that did not make any sense to
me everybody knew that the taliban had
been empowered in the last four years
during trump's presidency with the photo
op with him basically allowing it to
happen
trying to blame
all of us
deal with the real issue of the taliban
it's all well and good the international
community coming together saying that we
want to do something about it why aren't
they doing something about the countries
and people who are arming the taliban
those who are funding the taliban how
can it be that after 20 united states is
still running
the united states are the ones arming
the taliban right now we left all of
those weapons we left fighter jets we
let planes we left everything instead of
if anything burn
no no no listen listen i've already said
there is no defending the indefensible i
do expect i as far as i'm concerned that
this current administration should have
done better in evacuating withdrawing
but the point here is it did not happen
overnight let's not overlook that and
i'm saying that i agree that on the
ground right now americans are the ones
basically arming the taliban but it's
not just americans there are other
countries the same countries we shake
hands with over the g7 over the united
nations these are the people on the
countries that are arming and
incentivizing the taliban and we're
doing jack all about it and then people
get to congress people get to you know
uk parliament you know making all these
big speeches by doing jackal about
ending the problem and that is what we
need to do the taliban should not be
stronger than it was 20 years ago how is
that even possible okay we started with
you scotty we've ended with you that's
how it works it's good to talk to both
of you thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you
heated debate i wonder what you think at
home should we have known sooner what
was going to happen in afghanistan it
was red flagged by president trump and
then we also heard from president biden
he said that we're going in before the
11th of september all the troops are
being brought home we saw what happened
over the course of 10 days and then last
sunday when kabul was taken by the
taliban with little or no resistance and
since then uh one of the biggest
airlifts since the second world war
taking place to try to get as many
people back as possible another 300 on
airplanes we heard from the defense
secretary about to take off to come back
to the united kingdom for a new life
here what about those left behind
more on that comes throughout the course
of the day and also ahead of the tokyo
2020 paralympic games a global campaign
has been launched to support the 1.2
billion people living with disability
more
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up
out and have been used as missiles
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
we have now left italy and entered
france nobody's asked to check our
identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
[Applause]
do
[Music]
did you know that if we make small
changes to our lives we can reduce air
pollution by loads but how much exactly
loads
it's another gray and damp morning with
spots of rain and drizzle the light rain
may be rather persistent for parts of
eastern scotland and northeast england
noticeably cooler here elsewhere the
cloud will slowly break up to reveal
brighter spells but showery rain across
ireland will spread into wales and later
central england and some of the showers
could be on the heavy side
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high air pollution levels will
remain low at levels 1 to 3.
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
1.2 billion people 15 of the world's
population are people with a disability
just days before the tokyo paralympics a
global campaign has been launched to try
to increase awareness and inclusion as
lisa dowd reports
there is just 200 metres between richard
and another gold medal
the paralympics in tokyo are almost here
and he wants more than just the perfect
run
we as disabled people need to see to
believe it's possible and that's in all
areas of life whether that's sport
whether it's entertainment whether
that's in the workplace when we finish
our events when we get our gold medals
we go home and we're still disabled
people and we have so many obstacles and
challenges to overcome in life look at
you out and about push us all to be
better you are superheroes really yeah
we're superheroes all right
this will be played at the paralympics
opening ceremony to challenge
perceptions and drive change
the paralympics always reminds people of
just what is possible but many
paralympians believe that that moment of
appreciation is forgotten all too
quickly
those behind this global campaign say it
will last 10 years but you still have
them
every year big events not only the
paralympics but all the other sectors
will be connected as well because we do
want to change legislation in nations we
do want to have more persons with
disability in the media and not only
behind the camera but in front of a
camera we would like to see them in
hollywood you know why sometimes you
have to bring someone without a
disability to play the role of someone
with a disability gonna do taylor kelly
says the fight to change attitudes goes
beyond sport
after the paralympics everybody assumes
that you're a paralympian or that you
have the desire to be a paralympian and
that's not always the case you know i've
never even from a young age been really
interested in sport or been talented
enough to be a paralympian however i'm
an entrepreneur i've got three
businesses i've got a family
i
love work and i'm a successful and
positive person and to have yourself
pigeonholed so much into like one little
box is frustrating at times we pray five
times a day
and no
i'm not praying for a cure i'm praying
for a new handbag
fifteen percent of the world's
population are disabled the we the
fifteen movement wants to improve the
lives of those 1.2 billion people but
they know it'll take time
lisa dowd sky news
we uh of course the we'll be covering
the k the games i should say um in some
detail here on the breakfast show on sky
news before that though we want to talk
about what's happening in afghanistan
overnight we're going to be hearing from
our man
on the ground very shortly headlines for
you well hugely distressing pictures
and witnessed by our correspondent
stuart ramsey of babies being thrown
over fences in kabul a sign of the total
desperation of people there that they
want their children to get out even if
they can't themselves although ben
wallace told us that the soldiers who
are finding it very traumatic there
can't take a minor without their parents
so just the sifting operation in
afghanistan and the conditions on the
ground being so difficult